okay we're ready to go one three
two one go
hello everyone how's it going uh
this is rational science and welcome to
our little show
and we're here directly from frankfurt
germany
with my son anz i guess uh he's not my
favorite son but
you know i'm the one that's closest
around anyways uh
today we're gonna do a little review of
recap what uh happened this month here
on this channel
and uh yeah
make sure we get the sound no sound
should be there okay sorry you had a
little problem there with the sound
i'm always worried about these things
sometimes i talk for a while
then i find out two hours later that you
know the whole thing you can just throw
in the trash
okay anyways uh we're gonna divide our
little class today like uh
most of the time we're gonna do a little
bit of extinction first
uh do a little review of what happened
this month
typical most of it had to do with
quantum mechanics
and then we're going to first answer the
questions people have already asked
since last time and then we're going to
open the floor for up for uh new
questions and comments okay and so uh
yeah hello okay so let's get started
let's get the ball rolling here
and i'm going to start with a little
article that came out
this week has to do with anti-trust
okay and again this has to do with
extinction because it has to do with
the possible what i think is going to
happen the economic collapse
okay this is all related to that i think
it's going to go through the
realm of economics i think that's what's
going to happen okay and so that's
our argument here okay so here's the
first one okay
you want me to read these yeah why don't
you go ahead and read them
germany opens anti-trust probe against
apple
germany and france have joined calls
from the united states to impose a
global minimum corporate tax
of at least 15 percent a move which
targets multinationals like amazon and
google
yeah and you can see uh right at the
bottom it says um
it's going to go against amazon google
and facebook they've already
begun uh actions against these companies
and so the the first question is
you know whether this is going to
continue are they going to
go after all these big companies uh
isn't that
anti-capital maybe it's anti-trust but
it's anti-capitalism
it's like you know these people made it
up there they they made their money
should we go in there and uh do
something to them
and here you have another case and
that's got to do with
facebook and facebook instead in the
united states
one its case against the government here
it is
okay facebook wins anti-trust dismissal
surges to 1 trillion value
critics of facebook said the rulings
highlight the need to revise anti-trust
laws for the internet age you're saying
that they're coming out with new laws
against monopolies
yeah and um yeah what you're seeing is
that they're going after companies like
facebook
google amazon apple
possibly uh instagram i heard that as
well
so they're going after these big uh
octopuses they have their tentacles
everywhere right
and the question is uh well there's
several questions the first one is
whether we should do that is is that
better for humankind or not
you know or are they at fault are these
companies that fall or they're just
doing their thing and they grew
big because no one really
stopped them and then you have the the
issue of whether
this constant concentration of power
economic power influence uh conduces to
in some way to extinction does it
accelerate our extinction
if we break them up like you know here
you have the case is it sustainable i
guess
yeah here you have a case of uh 19 i
think 1984.
ah let me get it up here and this was
the break of
of a tnt they broke them up in all these
regions
and they're known as the baby bells
today well they were known
in those days i don't know if anyone
remembers that anymore
but they were known as the baby bells
because they broke up uh
bell telephone in you know several
pieces
and you can see they have all these
regions now and the question is
are they going to be doing this also
with um
with these big companies like facebook
and amazon and so on i mean
look at amazon amazon has gone out there
and also
uh began got into the business of
delivery
so they're no use they're no longer
using what they consider their
competitors now which is
uh you know companies like fedex and
usp and so on and now they're doing
their own deliveries
and you know what are they going to go
into next i mean restaurants and hotels
and
what is this monopoly they gave a
monopoly i'd buy uh
boardwalk and park place and start
charging money i mean what is it
eventually someone else ends up with all
the property right well it looks like
that isn't it inevitable that you have
to build in anti-trust laws just for
sustainability's sake
well uh we got two things here the first
one is
there there is some amount of
competition among the big guys
okay so at some point amazon is going to
collide with apple which is going to
collide with facebook which is going to
collide with instagram
so these big corporations are might
collide
more than likely will collide at some
point if they keep extending their
tentacles
like you know you have car companies you
know ford and gm and so on well they're
competing and so
uh is that a valid competition is that
what we call
competition or i mean
amazon's got ebay well this is what i
was getting to which we talked a little
bit about today with
and that's that if you put your little
old
uh company a car company you start in
your garage
right can you today build a company
as big as ford or ammo or um
general motors i mean you start your
little company right
do you think you could eventually
compete against these big guys
or or or is that already forbidden
forever
you know and if it's forbidden forever
does the fact that there are four or
fives
maybe 10 companies in the world i don't
know how many there are car companies
that are competing amongst themselves
mitsubishi and and whoever you and i and
so on
i mean this competition among giants
is that true competition or should we
get more little guys out there and have
you know
500 companies or a thousand companies
car companies
how should we do this what is the
optimal amount of companies
there we go and and that applies to any
one is the
bad answer we know that much one means
monopoly means they can do whatever they
want they have too much power
there's no checks and balances two is
that enough
or do they just end up shaking hands
well together well
just stop there stop at two i mean if we
had two monsters
you know out there in whatever business
you can think of there's only two in the
world
is that true competition the republicans
and the democrats
kind of like that i mean or should or
should we
or should we break whatever industry
whatever uh line item uh should we break
those up in
i don't know uh a hundred thousand or
maybe not that much but
a thousand is is a thousand better than
two wouldn't they work their way up to
two again
i mean what is the the end goal of
competition
monopoly you try to eliminate the
competition
okay uh getting back to a little bit
closer to extinction here we have um
another article that came out okay
someone
pointed it out to me and
this is about the permian extinctions
it's cause of the worst mass extinction
ever found
it's got to do with a permian extinction
huh
yeah yeah but this is the issue the
issue is we have
uh there was a mass extinction about 252
million years ago
and uh that's known as the biggest mass
extinction
because close to 90 percent of the
species disappear from the face of the
earth
and so they said what the hell happened
and so these guys say the following they
say uh
that you know these are the these are
the mechanisms they propose the causes a
new study reveals what caused most life
on earth to die
out during the end permian extinction
also known as the great dying well
that's a cool title yeah
great dying uh it's known as a cemetery
the study suggests a volcanic eruption
in siberia spread
aerosolized nickel particles that harmed
organisms on the planet
i guess a volcano shot out nickel
particles everywhere yeah but see this
is the
mechanic the specific mechanism here
comes nickel is an essential trace
metal for many organisms but an increase
in nickel abundance
would have driven an unusual surge in
productivity
of methanogens microorganisms that
produce methane gas
increased methane would have been
tremendously harmful to all
oxygen dependent life so there's too
much meth aaron's farting too much
well not only that but now see because
they they have
already had they already had um this
volcanic
activity you know that's what's being uh
ascribed to
or you know attributed to um to the
permian the
and permian because there was a mid
permian also extinction
map quite quite big mass extinction but
this is the end permian 252 million
years ago
uh this is the age of the garganops and
all these uh
uh pariah sars and so on these animals
that
uh were like mammal-like if you look at
them they're mammal-like reptiles if you
look at them they look like tigers and
lions
but when you dissect them and open them
up
they're reptiles they lay eggs
and imagine a lion laying eggs that's
more or less what you got here big bird
yeah yeah and so so the issue here is
these animals disappear
and the question and they've had the
idea that volcanic activity
was behind that okay they've had this
for a long time already
now they're going to the nitty-gritty
and these people are saying oh it was
the nickel that came out of volcanoes or
whatever
uh does that make any sense are we
making any progress on extinction
at all these people are going out there
looking for evidence
they don't have a valid theory they have
an idiotic theory that's the correct
uh qualifier they have an idiotic theory
and they're just looking for evidence to
certify their
their theory is that the way it should
work or should we
lay back he raised the board and tried
to try to think
how the animals could have died is that
a better way of doing it or
or is it going to be based on evidence
and this guy has this little piece of
evidence he said no no i was an asteroid
the other guy said well i don't think so
i think it was a volcano and the other
guys you know i think it was disease
or tons of evidence and you could come
up with any theory that's
possible but none of them really explain
selectivity
although if you're talking about ninety
percent and i mean
it's like there's not that much
selectivity going on in 90
that one could have been an asteroid no
no there is cell activity remember
yeah because there is cell activity
because that 10 of the animals that
survived that didn't fall in species
well you know what they had what
happened next they radiated
and they created the new species of
animals which were the uh
um what is it the uh
the uh archosaurs okay so they were like
uh crocodiles that
some of them supposedly walked on two
legs
you know they're kind of like the
dinosaurs they were already rising a
little bit
and so they're looking for evidence of
that nature they found
in fact they found some evidence of that
in
south korea and some kind of mountain
out there and they found
footprints 100 footprints preserved for
millions of years
and they found these footprints and and
by studying the footprints they said
look
these were people these were archosaurs
but
you know usually an animal steps on his
own footprint on the front footprint you
know
and so like the lion if you look at the
lion they film this
very carefully puts his uh
hind leg exactly where he put his front
leg
exactly i mean it's like he's got to
calculate it
uh his is because he's got to be very
careful not to
you know scare whatever prey he's after
so he's very
cautious in the way he walks and so is a
tiger and so on
and these animals they say is the same
thing you don't see the four paws on the
on the ground you see like two
you know bipedal animal and uh we're the
only bipedal
animal we know pretty much you know
there's a couple more out there and
that's
it and so they say that these archosaurs
were the first to stand on two legs and
then from there
one branch probably perhaps branched out
into the dinosaurs you know the
t-rex with a little yeah i'm thinking
velociraptors from jurassic park
yeah in fact all these uh velocirap
raptors and uh t-rexes and so on you
know
who was a robert baker one of the
paleontologists out there which
comes up with interesting theories he
said
you know we got the wrong idea he was
the first to propose as far as i know
that these were not cold-blooded
reptiles
they were hot-blooded chickens
i mean that kind of ruins yeah that's
scary like
it's not big chicken that's what that's
what a dinosaur guns are coming
it's a two-legged chicken in fact the
feet look more like chickens than
any reptile you know if you look at it
anyways uh
that's what you find in the uh permian
from this article
here's a from the same source this is
the triassic
okay and again look at the theories that
these people are proposing
and against a rock study may have just
revealed
cause of triassic mass extinction big
titles
does that make any sense clickbait
titles yeah it's a
a new study suggests that the mass
extinction that gave dinosaurs the
evolutionary upper hand was caused by
oceanic
oxygen deprevation in other words in the
other one it was also
was it nickel just being sprayed into
the air and
causing uh you know certain um gases to
form that killed animals in the land and
in the seas here we have what
also related to some gas in this case
oxygen
and they're saying you know there's uh
oxygen depletion
you know so so there's not enough air
and so
some of the animals i guess gasped to
that that's the thing these are always
these like wide
like area of effect kind of uh effects
so
everything in that area should die
really why is it leaving the small
things alive
yeah and if you look at uh it says 60
percent
of plant species also died that's kind
of coincidental that
the plant species also died uh
oh did they die because some gas was out
there why didn't they all die
and it turns out that what died again
it's uh what i
always want you to look for is it was a
chronological
extinction what died were the old plants
and the old animals
what survived were the new plants and
the new animals if you look at that
you'll see that in
every mass extinction no exceptions okay
so it's a hundred percent
uh that old plants and old animals die
and
the ones that have been around for a
long time and uh the ones that survive
are the new ones the ones that radiate
right after the extinction that had
nothing to do with what
with their food chain and there you can
see the uh
the causes what is it climate change
asteroid impacts volcanoes
that's it so that's all they can think
of and
that you know it's always the
environment
explosions and here's uh one site
uh another site but again this is a
site known as spot coal okay
same thing that's all they can propose
and so
i just want to make sure people
understand that we have something a
little different that's what we propose
okay here we have the overturning of the
demographic uh
pyramid for plants you mean this is the
theory you propose yeah this is my
theory i'm saying
uh what happened was over time um
the plants that been around for millions
of years
finally you know they give up their
genetic diversity their population
pyramid overturns you start having fewer
and fewer of these plants
they are old plants that means that they
are not as sophisticated as the new ones
yeah the new ones uh for example when we
went from spores
to cones cone spread faster than spores
and and to a wider range and then when
the angiosperms came around
they replaced the the cones in other
words conifers the
gymnosperms did you call it new
technology
yeah in a certain sense if you compare
you know even today if you compare the
conifers against the angiosperms the
angiosperms beat the hell out of them
because they have encased
seeds so this seed can last longer out
there without it being
destroyed by the environment by
environmental
conditions or whatever or an animal
eating it on the other hand the cone
lasts
less and the spore is even more
primitive so we went from
from first uh non-vasculars
and we went from those to um
to what is it ferns which
were primarily with spores there were
some seed firms as well
then we went to conifers
and fighting with angiosperms so so
mother nature
improved her way of
of reproducing plants and so when one
plant uh
was dying because it was already at the
end of its life it
exhausted its genetic diversity and on
top of it it's got this
big competitor next to it that's uh you
know taking over the land
what happens to the animals that
depended on that source of food for
millions of years
and that's the second part there the ego
the the first part has to do with a
background extinction
meaning it's a genetic and population
uh extinction whereas the second one has
to do with an ecological
extinction which follows yeah because it
means that now the
herbivores don't can't find as much food
they can't find these
they're stuck on an island and the
island is shrinking on them i call it
the shrinking island
they're stuck on some island some forest
uh some jungle
and they're eating whatever they eat but
that jungle is becoming smaller and
smaller and smaller
the animals are becoming bigger and
bigger and bigger
as a result of cope's law as it's known
that over time animals get bigger and
bigger especially through this
competition you know the t-rexes didn't
come
on earth like uh like god put them for
the first
day like when they disappeared now the
t-rexes were animals that over time they
grew and grew and grew
big why because they were in a
competition against
uh hadrosaurs and ankylosaurus and
against uh
um what other animals and against uh the
uh what is it the the horned ones after
serotonin
yeah triceratops you know these animals
were growing bigger fishing triceratops
which in
montana you know hell creek montana um
that's where the big fight between two
rex's and
yeah it was a it was a
like the united states and russia you
know this guy builds one weapon the
other guy builds another
it's a it's an arms race and so this guy
becomes bigger the other guy becomes
bigger and over time they grew but i
want to watch that movie
well you gotta wait two three minutes
yeah but it's a two-three million year
movie
yeah i don't know where you gotta watch
it in times ten speed
okay so uh here it is uh oh you can see
you can see um uh how this progress what
are we looking at what we're looking at
here the
uh paleozoic the mesozoic and the
xenozoic and what what you see here is
that
when we started out we started out with
you know right at the very bottom in the
devonian
you've got titalic there that little uh
animal that just
was somewhat like a lung fish it could
live in the water and also in
in uh on land one of the first
animals that came out on to land they
say it's the talent or
you know some of its cousins and then by
the time you get
into the carboniferous you you start
seeing uh the world of amphibians
and they ruled the world at the time
they were the kings okay
and then after that you got you know the
uh um
pelicosaurs okay you got the uh big
sailbacks
okay like dimetrodon and uh
uh inefficiaris and some some of those
animals
and and then uh from there they worked
uh
midway into the permian the second half
uh those animals disappeared what
continued where these uh
uh thoraxids and from there they uh they
moved on to these uh thicker dots the uh
archesaurs and so on
from there they moved on to dinosaurs
and there were two types of dinosaurs
the ones that were in the jurassic
the ones that were in the tri and the
cretaceous
they were different kinds of dinosaurs
okay so if you look you'll see
that very different types of um
dinosaurs
and i say that that's got a lot to do
with the
foods that they ate in part in other
words when they
radiated they radiated with the
radiation of food as well in other words
the
the plant life and based on that those
animals that could make the most of that
plant life were the ones that grew
and became the big monsters of the
jurassic when they all died a new
branch of dinosaurs continued they had
different types of food they grew they
do stuff well they yeah they they uh
radiated with
new types of plants and they grew into
different types of uh animals in general
essentially two different food chains
yeah the old food chain
goes dying because the plants die off
and then that that
from the bottom up the chain kind of
dissolves and while that's all
going on the new food chain slowly has
more room to grow
so they get bigger and you can see that
there's a difference between
dinosaurs or the cretaceous versus the
ones in the jurassic
just like there are differences in the
mammal-like reptiles
of the permian you know a theropod is
not the same thing as a pelicans are
and they were very different types of
animals in many ways
especially you can see just uh one's got
a sailback looks more like a
reptile and the other guy looks more
like a lion so so they were different
kinds of animals
but once the the second group the
theropods they came
out of the first guys okay and then
towards the right you see
the mammals and we started around the
jurassic we were tiny animals throughout
the jurassic
uh there i put two examples the
megazostrodon
and purgatorious in the cretaceous
and these animals supposedly not these
specific animals
uh sometimes uh the paleontologists uh
like to exaggerate and say we came out
of these
no no it was some cousin of this these
guys that were
parallel to to these guys these are the
guys we see in the rock but they're
getting
there had to be lots of other mammals
out there
that eventually turned into the ones
that radiated once the dinosaurs were
gone
and so this is in general terms the big
picture
and just i'm looking here at only at the
animals on land
and here you see uh in a bigger picture
in fact you can see probably a better
picture
of what really happened and what
happened throughout the ages you have
uh there again you see tiktaalik on the
total
to the left is the history of life yeah
this is the history of life on earth and
these are just
samples for each age you can see that
there were different types of animals
throughout the period
but i want to what i want to point out
is that what happened to the plants
and you can see that the age of
amphibians is thought is uh
related to the non-vascular and early
vasculars
then the permian triassic or the age of
seed ferns in general terms triassic is
also known for
uh some of the uh or the cycads that
came out
um and you know and
there's a specific seed firm also that
uh
i think was very important throughout uh
those days
and um uh what was the name of it i
forgot
forget the nails remember in a minute um
uh
oh like dicrodiums that's that's what
their names
anyways then uh they moved uh into the
jurassic and cretaceous age of dinosaurs
we call them
and these were the age of uh gymnosperms
uh different types of gymnosperms in
jurassic than in cretaceous
okay you see different types of plants
um and by the time we get to our uh
era uh you know all the conifers and the
uh
ferns all these all these plants they
become a small
part of the landscape and today it's
almost all angiosperms
i don't know how much there is i think
75 percent of the planet has angiosperm
especially with humans you know
specifically
planting these things you know we're
we're muscling aside all the other
types of plants that we have no use for
other than for beauty
for for beautiful landscapes so this is
in general terms what happened and what
i'm saying you can see that
when certain plants died the animal died
like i showed a minute ago in the
triassic sixty percent of the
or i think it was the uh permea i can't
remember which two
right now but sixty percent of the
plants died like
isn't that a clue of something if the
plants die the the herbivore is going to
die right that depended on that plant
and what you will see
is that at every mass extinction there's
always
always a massive plant extinction
a plant a type of plant an order of
plants that existed or
thrived through millions of years and
then suddenly you know whittled away and
finally died
and what happens to the animals that
affords their relationship with that
they're gone and with them the the uh
carnivores had hunted them they go to
the fridge and there's nothing there
yeah okay uh someone mentions this
uh well this is uh this is the
introduction okay let me go with the
introduction first this is what i said
the other day and i'll just go
briefly through it a seller is a person
who what who gives
and what is a buyer a person who
receives period
and and the rest of the predicate there
should be removed
uh because when when we say a buyer
uh we're not insinu we're insinuating
that um he's giving something in
exchange
but it's that's not very clear what is
absolutely clear is that he's going to
receive something that's what we call a
buyer
buyer's the guy who receives something
if he gave something he's a seller
okay well the context here is that
i'll get to the context so we start with
this saying these are the definitions
seller is a giver buyers are receivers
away from dynasty yeah i i had to well
yeah because it's got to do with uh
remember the extinction
the economic collapse okay that's what
it's where we headed
okay so here we have we distinguish
between a buyer and a seller because one
has to do with capitalism the other one
has to do
with uh communism what is communism well
a receiver who doesn't give
and what is a capitalism a giver who a
giver who does
receive okay if you have a receiver who
who doesn't give we call it communism
you have a giver who doesn't receive we
call communism again what's a giver who
does that
well again that's why i defined a seller
and buyer
not as someone who's interested in where
the goods go
yeah i'm just saying one guy just
receives the other guy gives
otherwise if the guy gives something for
something we call him a seller
we don't call him a receiver
a buyer okay so okay so that's the
context
and so the reason i raise this is
because someone a couple people
uh ask questions regarding this okay
so let me put this up here and this is
what the person says
we trade seller seller yeah because i
mentioned that
trade is seller seller there's no buyer
but
might i suggest the word producer all
free independent men are expected to
produce for their own benefits
self-interest those who cannot depend on
the generosity love or voluntary
commitment of those who can give
uh-huh and another person doubles up on
that
also talking about producer and says
producers are gatherers
who are engaging in trade selling what
they have
okay so these are uh what people propose
maybe we should call them producers and
i don't know i i don't like the word
producer let me tell you why here it is
okay this is my take on this okay
producer versus parasite yeah yeah we're
gonna
compare a producer versus a parasite
okay okay and and here we have a
specific case my own son
hans let me put him up there again for a
second okay
that's him and it turns out you know
when when uh he was young you know
he would come to me and say dad give me
a lounge give me twenty dollars
allowance i said what twenty dollars i'm
not gonna give you a penny
and he says okay then uh i'm gonna bug
you all day i'm gonna make your life
miserable today
and it's what i call you know the uh
uh and so uh here we have what i call
the allowance tony says you need
protection
theory which is if you don't give money
he's going to bug you all day and cry
and you know do all kinds
and you know throw a fit so uh so i call
it the allowance theory or the
time he says you need protection so the
guy's not producing anything but you got
to give them money
because otherwise he breaks the windows
of your shop are we just categorizing
forms of making money no well well here
let me show you this i'm getting to that
last line that's going to clarify i
think
completely first i want to make sure
that producer is not a seller which is
what these people are proposing they're
saying
why don't you use the word producer
instead of seller well because you have
carpenter that yeah
one is the farmer who makes the fruit
and then there's the guy who sells it or
what
no no that's one issue because if uh if
i'm a farmer and i give it to a seller
i'm selling it too
but this is the issue if i'm a carpenter
that makes a table for myself
then i'm i'm a producer but i'm not a
seller am i selling to myself
what does that mean or a subsistence
farmer he produces
he has a garden or whatever just
produces for his own consumption
is that a seller so a producer is not a
seller so i don't think we can replace
the word seller
directly with the word producer then
there's the other issue
and there's the issue of parasites there
are all kinds of parasites
there's people who can't there's people
who can but won't
and there's people who can't but can't
every person is pretty strong
okay so let's go through each one person
who can maybe a quadriplegic or someone
who um
is on life support he's there he's alive
he can't
he can't do or he's a child he can't
produce
anything worthwhile okay then you have
the those that
can but won't and i was thinking of the
queen of england
and freddie the freeloader a red skelton
who used to do that
bit you know the bum who just begs and
doesn't give anything in return
especially work or anything at all and
then you have those that can but can't
and those are the people who want to
work and can't find
work because the economy does not allow
for it okay and here you have uh
this would happen in the uh depression
why can't you give my dad a job that's
what i keep asking
[Laughter]
uh so uh so we have all these situations
so i don't think we can replace the word
um seller with a word producer and then
we have to distinguish people who are
parasites but are not parasites
of their own free will okay there are
those who don't want to work and don't
care
especially now that all this covid money
is out there hey people are
a lot of people are happy and they don't
want to even go back to work uh
a lot of them and that's one issue but
then there's
a lot of people who for whatever reasons
they can't work
there they have physical problems or
whatever
and then there are those who want to
work and they can't find work
okay and so there's there's a mixture
there so you have to be careful
with the word producer here as well
because there are people who want to
produce
and you might treat them as a bum
because you say well you're not
producing well yeah because i can't
because
either you know you have a physical
problem or you can't find a job
is that that person's fault you know i
mean there's one job ten people
apply nine people are gonna be out of a
job that sort of thing and
you can't always cover 10 uh 100
in fact um for as long as we can
remember
unemployment is part of every economy in
the world whether a communist or or
capitalist there's always a percentage
of unemployment
and that unemployment has to be
sustained with welfare some kind of
welfare socialism or whatever
there's no other way and that person
otherwise you know has to go out there
and
you know buy a gun with whatever money
he's got
so you know just keep all these things
in mind okay
okay moving on here uh
here we go one guy says
bitcoins uh cryptocurrency
these scam coins are getting crazy yeah
uh someone just showed me this one and
he goes through how many millions of
each one of these coins there are and
some of them are unlimited
have no cap and so on um yeah
bitcoin is i think uh simply the new
currency
that's out there okay and here you um
today i pulled this out this these are
the 10 most
popular coins uh there's hundreds of
them now and these are all
crypto coins you can see that the trends
are going up so a lot of people are
getting into this market
i guess this uh bitcoin or i call them
bitcoin but it's crypto
currency uh in general it's going to go
up maybe it's a good time to buy because
these are all pyramids
meaning that it's expected that more and
more people will
enter buy the coin and take the prices
upwards and so right now maybe it's a
good time to get into this
don't take my advice just in case but
it's just
something for you to ponder you know uh
in fact the other day i got into the
bitcoin
market i bought some uh dogecoin
you know i bought just just to play
around just to find out what it would do
you know put my money where my mouth is
and i bought 150 worth of uh dogecoin
and it went up to 300 bucks and then i
sold so i made
twice my money if someone would have
done the same thing with i don't know a
million bucks he would have had two
million bucks and so on
so maybe now this time now is the time
to get into crypto for those who
who want to
[Laughter]
yeah i don't think i could manipulate
the market too much with 150 bucks but
we're gonna go up to 450 and we keep
talking yeah that's where people like
elon musk you know who
can put in there a billion bucks and
then sell it the next day
and have the market go soon we'll have
500
okay so maybe it's a good time for you
to consider but
my point here is that crypto yeah is is
um
i think it's the new currency it might
replace i don't know if it will
but it might replace the old currency
which is uh
fiat money or or even checking accounts
which is kind of
like an abstraction crypto yeah they
they did they was a sign of the end
times
it was the rock market when the rex
market collapsed
yeah yeah poor dude okay
another issue here um says has
has bill explained the selectivity
problem
regarding dinos i mean some species
would have adapted better than others to
white well uh to the environment in
other words if there are climate change
and food changes for example
you know uh one usually dependent on the
other
what this fellow is saying i guess is if
the climate changes and the food changes
well the big guys die okay because they
cannot
adapt fast enough why not uh well again
you gotta explain the mechanism but they
just
uh say that's the theory in other words
it's the conclusion without
putting in a mechanism they're just
saying the big guys die because they
suck at adapting
yeah once the second adapting happens
and the issue there that i always have
which is important is you know forget
about the big guys
any animal take a rabbit he's eating
lettuce he loves lettuce or any of these
little
you know these plants that he eats every
day can
this rabbit switch over to ferns or
conifers can he start eating pine trees
tomorrow i'm sure they tried and
i'll tell you that they can't you know
in fact
i read once that uh horses when they eat
by mistake
some of these conifers uh they get
either sick or die they they
it really affects it because they're not
used to this kind of uh
plant first of all and second i don't
think they have the
bacteria the proper bacteria in their
bodies to to
you know digest it to digest this kind
of uh
food anyways they just get stuck with
rocks in their stomach it's the second
part that uh
that he was really after many smaller
species would have lost
larger predators as for plants they'd
have winners and losers too
yeah in other words this fellow is
saying that uh the small species
right once the big guy once the big guys
well let me
yeah let me get this here ah
once the big guys are out of the way he
says well uh
that that would explain why the little
guy survived
and to a point he's right the question
is whether they're
part of the same food chain and the way
i get to this
is through uh my fable uh
of the lion and the fly okay and so
here's the fable of the lion and the fly
okay
and so here we have a lion let me put it
over here
[Laughter]
and so he started going after flies okay
well he found out that it was very hard
to catch a fly you know there were lots
of lies but he couldn't catch a single
one because they were so fast
and he could just grab them and eat them
and after a lot of uh you know chasing
after around him he finally caught one
of them
and he ate it but it didn't satisfy him
very much
and so he found out that not only did it
didn't taste very good or as good as a
buffalo
uh that was one issue the other one took
him a lot of energy right
to to catch one of these flies it took
him a lot of effort
and so it wasn't worth it for him now
imagine imagine now
you're going back to the cretaceous and
you've got these
t-rexes right picking or you know any
velociraptors or any of these
and you know and and they're running
around chasing after these
mice the purgatorius or any of these
small mammals that were
there in those days and i can imagine
these little animals running around
their feet like
like rats today running around our feet
do you think
uh t-rex would have the dexterity you
know the
swiftness to catch one of these guys for
catching them first of all that
second they probably didn't taste good
any more than a you know a bug would
taste good for you you know
do you generally eat uh grasshoppers or
cockroaches not typically maybe someone
does out there but uh
not typically you haven't seen lion king
pose you know what happens in lion king
right
yeah simba eats the freaking bugs yeah i
know because
but this is the issue the issue is
i doubt very much i doubt very much the
t-rex would spend the time to go after
purgatorious and his crew first of all
second
i doubt very much they could catch him
maybe stomp on them i don't know
by mistake and then it's a potato chip
and it doesn't fill him no he's not
going to even waste time on these little
these are nuisances you know that are in
the way so
this notion that the big guys left of a
when they left
that's why the little guys could expand
well they could expand yeah that's one
issue but
whether they were part of the same food
chain that's a separate issue
i don't think flies are part of the same
food chain as lions okay and similarly
similarly i don't think that uh mammals
were part of the food chain
of most uh predators
dinosaurs right okay uh another fellow
says
says there are people there are people
achieving
self-sufficiency in urban environments
by doing such things
as aquaponics a system that raises fish
and plants
fertilizer with fish waste some
raised some chicken pheasant quail small
pigs
in the backyard feeding families of four
easily
yeah today that's that's the difference
today
today we can do that because we have the
protection we have protection from the
law we have the
judges we have the police we have the
air force everybody protects you
okay so we have this system that we've
developed that we all
agree upon we all well most of us
uh promise to follow and because we
follow it then
no problem we go in there and uh you
know
um we can plant we can plant
successfully
the issue here that uh you gotta answer
is
you know can you do this when the
global economy collapses and what you
have is no 9-1-1
that's the the issue is defense the
issue is security
uh a thousand and and then there's
there's a couple more issues which i
raised the other day i'll just mention
them
quickly and ask that first one person
cannot um plant
i don't know uh 100 acres let's assume
he can because he's got the right tools
and machinery the tractors the combines
whatever he's got okay he he plants 100
acres
can he defend 100 acres here you have
thousands of people coming from the city
they're starving
there's food there in your in your great
farm your beautiful farm
you planted took all this trouble to
work and plant your field
and now they come and they start uh
pouncing upon your
100 acres it doesn't have to be hundred
acres but you know there's new
technology where they do 3d
planting yeah where it goes up so you
can you save a lot of room
yeah okay so vertical vertical i guess
what we're saying is in an ideal
world if everyone were really good at
farming we all had aquaponics and 3d
farming and whatnot and we're all super
efficient maybe we could all just
sustain our own food but i guess you're
counter to that is the transition
between our world and that ideal world
yeah i'm referring i'm referring to
normal
to right now we have a normal world yeah
people can
plant whatever they want they can do
aquaponics or whatever they want to do
not that many people know about it
no no but assuming you know uh yeah
there are people out there surviving
with it no problem
but uh a lot of them are preppers
they're preparing for who knows what
but they're preparing for some
catastrophe but the issue here is that
what happens when the global economy
collapses let's assume that
we're going to make an assumption global
economy collapses there's no more money
meaning no one produces more food except
those
who are qualified and have the land to
do that
and so these people produce you think
anyone else is going to respect
property after the global economy
collapses
now they're hungry people they're
desperate people a lot of them have guns
they're going to go out there and just
eat your farm alive
they're going to be like the locust
there's it's going to overrun your farm
what are you going to do shoot them all
even assuming you shoot a lot of them i
don't think you can shoot them all
i don't think you can patrol your whole
land if you because if you're going to
be living for at least a year
with all this food that you planted you
got quite a bit of land there just to
feed yourself let alone if you have more
people in your group
and then again you have to have a little
group they have to
patrol the whole land you have all these
people from the city
just swarming over your your farm with
guns also
i don't know if you can protect it the
issue is protection there's no 9-1-1
after the global economic collapse there
is but they're not there to help you
no yeah if they come with guns
uh they're not there to protect you we
heard there was food here i mean a
disturbance
okay l says those billionaires
talking about living it on other planets
i assume
must be just gaming the idiots who fall
for it to somehow make money
if not that then they are just total
retards
the true meaning of the word what is the
context
about you switch topics real quick yeah
no because they're all related to
extinction here
the other day we talked about leaving
the planet so that we avoid extinction
and uh elon musk said you know we
we have to become a more than one planet
species he says a multi-planet species
carl sagan says a two planet species and
so on
uh jeff bezos says we should take all
the
machinery on earth all the factories all
these
two shootings and take them to space or
to
the moon we should use the moon for
manufacturing and this should be a
pristine garden and so they have all
these ideas
and so elon musk has this spacex program
he wants to go into mars
the question is that if that's ever
going to happen where we have this
beautiful landscape here on earth and
you're going to move to mars voluntarily
to live in these
bubble cities what i call bubble cities
uh
looks cool i don't think so in the
desert maybe for one day visit and great
i mean
one week whatever if there's people
there what's the difference well the
issue is that i don't know if people
want to live there first of all but
assuming will this ever happen will
anyone build
cities on mars and these people are
saying they will that we have to
we have to do it before world war three
which is coming up probably
and so they're hurrying up they said we
need to send someone into
to mars each other yeah because if we
knew
each other here at least we'll have a
million people out there that can
continue to propagate you know what
i actually i have a counter to that if
we have a backup plan and there's people
living on mars
then we're gonna go no no no but
assuming we had people on mars right
that means we have the carte blanche to
nuke each other
so isn't it better to just have one
planet so we all respect each other and
not make each other
yeah and there's more than that i mean
uh do you want to live in a bubble city
or do you want to
have a planet i mean if we could like
sagan suggested that we terraform
mars such that we can live on the
surface without these bubbles
protecting us without the suits that we
could just breathe
that's a problem already first because
gravity is different there and that
means it's not going to hold the air
to the surface of mars as it is here
therefore the pressure
the pressure is lower etcetera etcetera
i said there's many problems
we're living on mars even in an
idealistic situation
let alone if we have to build these
artificial bubbles and build the cities
within the bubbles
uh and where are we gonna get all these
supplies are we gonna ship them from
focus and damas the moons of mars i
thought we just catapulted by the
teaspoons
so now i think this is all baloney these
people are talking nonsense and so is
nasa when
nasa says oh we got to go out into outer
space
we're not going to go out there and live
there we're not going to call on
can we explore yeah to learn stuff or
do some research that's great are we
actually going to
colonize and live on mars oh that's a
difference hold on but i think this is
isn't this why you
went into extinction theory in the first
place because assuming we did live
forever like the species
wouldn't it be a temporal inevitability
that eventually
we would like overcrowd earth and just
be like you know what
now we need more room we're all
suffering down here let's go to mars
yeah i got into the extinction business
because of relativity
because book after book that i read they
all said
we're going to go out of the out of the
earth we're going to go through
through the fourth dimension to another
universe they started talking about all
this
nonsense this idiocy you know talking
about wormholes and so on and i said
what the hell is all this
these people and that's when i started
analyzing because until then i believed
as well
or i had in the back of my mind i never
really uh
dealt with this question in any depth
and so i casually just believe yeah
we're going to conquer those
planets it's it's almost automatic that
at some point we're just going to go out
of the earth conquer the planets then
conquer the stars and conquer the galaxy
everyone kind of takes it like a matter
of fact yeah future thing like
not us but eventually yeah yeah we leave
it to the
future generation it's going to happen
like and then i started analyzing that
there's no way
it's like me with my chores leave it up
to tomorrow me procrastination yeah
they'll do it so uh no i
i started looking and said there's no
way we're going to mars
not to colonize i mean we might go to
mars to go around to
send some robots maybe some humans there
that
pull some rocks and bring them back that
sort of thing no problem they look at
the landscape they had a great vacation
maybe a month or so and then it can be
just saying not to colonize but
colonize that's a totally different
issue because now you got to take a lot
of stuff there
which costs lots of money every trip
costs gazillions of dollars
all the money it's it's a cost issue
right now we can't
you know we're dying as far as uh
extra money on earth uh a lot of poor
people they're gonna have to sustain
those people with welfare that means
it's gonna
take money out of someone okay here's a
question for you there's not gonna be
any money for this here's the question
assuming we did assuming there were no
human
uh apocalypse coming
wouldn't you you're saying we would
prefer to live
the rest of human existence here on
earth
you're saying that's what we would
choose we would choose the majority
great majority but i mean i mean you're
saying it
would never happen that we would build
up enough resources to go to mars
we wouldn't be we wouldn't build up
enough resource that's one
issue there's the technology part can we
take all this stuff that we need over
there
in many trips again maybe that could be
an issue of money
but ultimately it's an issue of money
anyways because there are more
pressing issues here on earth and i'm
sure
uh congresses in every country in russia
in china in the united states they have
better things to do
with the money than to create a colony
somewhere where they're never going to
go
you know the senators doesn't just take
one etc eccentric billionaire to
just do it without anyone's consent i
think it takes a little more than that
yeah we have that we have that right now
we have people like amazing
and uh what's his name uh
i was gonna say trump but all these rich
guys
uh are they gonna pull all their money
and create trillions of dollars and send
many troops to mars to build a colony
and lies
when they're not going to go to mars
where they're going to send it's just
are they going to send
others just for posterity well are they
going to get it are they going to do it
for
other people that's the question for
themselves for posterity to leave their
minds why are they gonna do that yeah
i don't think they would why not if
they're bored i if i had a trillion
bucks
i'd do it just to be the guy who did it
you're gonna die anyway you might as
well do something with your trillions
yeah but uh
uh when i disagree yeah let me let me
let me tell ya
i over with you how about one of the
things i always say
is you know you have all these um
philanthropists uh rich people
millionaires they're all philanthropists
they say i'm gonna give half my money
away i'm going to give a quarter i'm
going to give
75 next year they end up being always
the richest people on earth you say how
can they
give so much money out their
philanthropist they're
giving all this money away for free to
this
project to that other one over there and
they always end up
always always at the top of the of the
rich man's pile so i think that a lot of
these people are
so-called philanthropists just to reduce
their taxes
so they can declare less taxes i don't
think there's any real
philanthropy out there or at least not
significant there is some
obviously but i'm wondering about how
how do you end up always being on the
top
uh of the richest people on earth if
they give so much of their money away
but isn't that obvious
what's obvious they don't give enough
away because they're not
you know they want to keep being able to
give away but that's my point my point
if
if that guy really gave up half his
fortune away i would probably believe
him
you know next year i believe him well in
the sense that the guy says
this year i'm gonna uh i'm so generous
i'm gonna give half my money away so the
guy's got
i don't know 500 billion dollars he's
going to give 250 billion dollars
of his own money and just send it out
right he's no longer the owner of that
money but he can't it never happened it
never happened never will because he
can't continue his business
no he don't he can give that money away
he could do a lot of good
i don't know good because when you give
money away you do good and bad yeah a
little bit of everything and
we're all aware but this is my point my
point is
if the guy promises to do something like
that it actually does it then maybe i
would believe him because now he's no
longer the richest guy in the world
maybe he falls to number 20 or 100. i've
never seen that
i've never seen that you know the joke
of the father giving his son
advice for the future he says you need
two things uh
what is it with the truth and wisdom
he tells them truth always come through
on a promise
if you promise even if you lose your
whole business
no matter what always come through on a
promise and what about wisdom father
and the father sells some wisdom to
never make a promise
especially that he can't keep or that he
doesn't want to keep
something okay let's continue here
moving on um
uh yeah we're gonna move on now with uh
the june
recap let's go over that i thought
that's what we're doing uh yeah but this
is the specific part related to physics
okay so what do we cover primarily
quantum mechanics okay
and we talked about computers if you can
touch it
if you can see it it's not called
quantum should not be called quantum
it's called classical okay and so what
these people say oh we have a quantum
computer
what do you mean by quantum computer you
mean
there's something i can't touch or see
in the quantum computer
no they say we we looked at all these um
phenomena
and we saw the coherence we saw
entanglement we saw superposition
and we know how to manipulate it yeah
you know how to manipulate it for
technology but you don't understand it
why do you call it a quantum computer
when it's a classic
the classical part is the one that you
can touch or see
the intangible part the one that you
call quantum
you can't and you can't explain it so
what's the point just the same that
i saw this effect and i applied it to
technology
and i made this computer which is faster
or whatever right
is that why we call it a quantum
computer it sounds better than classical
computers yeah
because if you say classical people say
oh you're you're still in the 19th
century the marketing guys
got in on the quantum computer i can
sell that yeah
then you have uh we went over the
measurement problem what is that well
how and whether uh wave function
collapse occurs
what is this uh again that's the
measurement problem it's called the
measurement problem in quantum mechanics
it's weather if and when right
uh wave function collapse occurs and the
inability
of the observer to see this uh this
collapse
right directly uh has given rise to many
interpretations of quantum mechanics you
have the copenhagen interpretation which
was championed by
borin heisenberg and bourne and a couple
others
many worlds uh hugh everett came up with
that
nonsense that for every step you take
you branch off on a different
universe that's the explanations they
give to the wave function collapse
hidden variables uh championed by baum
and
others again that i think well einstein
also was in
podolski and rose and they were also
behind this hidden variables
um interpretation they say there's stuff
that we do not
know about the party so the particle
itself has
properties that we're not aware of what
is the measurement problem
well the measurement problem is there uh
how or whether wave function collapses
well that's when you have this wave and
it's a function and so on
it's an equation and when the equation
collapses it turns into a particle what
do you mean the equation collapses yeah
that's exactly what i mean the equation
collapse that's the way
like you crumple the paper up kind of
like that but you're taking this concept
this abstract concept which is
a wave function not the wave but the
function that describes the wave
and the function collapses and they
called away from you
they need to do that because they need
to give a physical interpretation to
what happened
uh how can we summarize it very simply i
feel bad roasting you for this when
you're
trying to parrot the the explanations of
another yeah
let me put you back in here for a second
this is the issue this is summaries
like this and it's not my summary of
someone else's okay and that's that
uh what is light well it says light
travels as a wave and starts off
and arrives as a particle that
essentially summarizes
the measurement problem and it's got to
do with complementary the principle of
complementary
that niels bohr came up with that means
that
the light is both a particle and a wave
the electron is both a particle in a way
what do they mean by that
they rephrase it in a different way they
don't say it is they say
it behaves as okay and they think with
that they got away with saying what it
is
and what they're really saying is that
light
and the electron are both light have uh
wave and particle properties
the wave property is only when it's
traveling
and at beginning at source and at target
that's when it converts into a particle
because the wave function
collapses to a part it's like this
elongated thing suddenly
from the whole universe remember in the
case of uh the electric field
uh as soon as you measure it the the
field extends throughout the universe
all the way to the edge of space time
and suddenly collapses to a point
local so that you can measure it yeah no
or it's the other way around when you
measure it collapses
well that's very accommodating yeah yeah
it is because now you touched it
and someone they don't know why now you
looked at it now you touched it
now what happens the whole universe of
that
specific uh thing that you're measuring
the whether it's the photon or the
electron
suddenly collapses from this elongated
thing that stretches throughout the
universe
to a localized point
and you ask okay no problem
what's the mechanism and they say let me
show you some math we can explain it
mathematically because they have some
they don't have clues
in the math and then they give
extrapolated yeah extrapolate
they just extrapolate it because they
have to give a physical interpretation
why because otherwise their math would
be
irrelevant and no one cares about it if
if you can't relate the math to the real
world
to physics what was the point of doing
that math that exercise and say oh look
here's here's an equation we have this
tautology
this side of the equal sign equals the
other side it's a fun puzzle maybe
yeah but then what does it have to do
with reality
okay so continuing here uh here we have
um
the quantum dot technology okay
also under the influence of light
electrons are excited and
quantum jump okay up to a higher energy
band and also
lower so so this uh this electron
goes up and down and what it does they
look at the
how much it jumped and it's a measure of
the energy
that uh that the quantum dots they
create these dots
physically again uh classical stuff
because they're
moving molecules around they are able to
concentrate them
and because of the structure of that
molecule because of its shape
and also because of the energy level it
uh emits a different color light
and they play around with and that's why
they can give you a sharper color
that supposedly replaces some of the
older technologies again it's got to do
with technology
this quantum dot that's not the issue
the issue we want to know
understand is how does it do it and for
that you got to go
at the atomic level because if you're
going to talk about
an electron that's jumping from energy
levels
from the for example from the valence
band to the conduction band which is
where they say this
occurs between those two levels then the
question is fine
great these are what is why is it levels
away from the proton
yeah yeah that's all it is essentially
you know so you have
essentially uh you know different
conductances the conduction level
really has nothing to do with the atom
because the atom ends at the valence
band
that is the atom what continues after
that is known as empty space
and so what these people are saying is
that the electron
jumps from the valence band from its
outer electron
shell to no man's land meaning
now it's in the conduction and now it's
free to move around and that's why we
call it the conduction band
right because now it's a part of
electricity now i can move
anywhere at once and you say fine oh
great i'll concede
what is the mechanism what makes it jump
and they talk about energy levels and
give you the mathematical equation
that's not what we want that's a
description
i want to know the mechanism and before
we can get to that i need to see your
atom and find out why that electron
doesn't fall
to the center to the nucleus or why does
it spontaneously fly away drift away
what keeps it at what keeps it in the
valence band what keeps it in the ur
in the in the uh closer bends to the
nucleus why doesn't the electron just
fly away
if the electrons jumping it's got legs
right
uh yeah it's jumping up and down off of
the proton
well here you see it okay there it is
that that's the model
uh you have a photon come in there
energy whatever they call it
and it when it does it hits it into a
higher level
and then the when the electron loses
energy it falls to the lower level
great okay so we we're talking about
energy whatever energy is
it gains and loses energy arrow yeah but
that's the energy yeah and so uh what is
all that nonsense i mean why doesn't
that electron fall spontaneously
to the center of the uh atom which is
the nucleus because the nucleus has the
positive protons the
electron is negative it should fall
directly to the nucleus there's
something keeping it away but not so
so way that flies and so the question is
you know
what the hell is that i need to see your
atom before you can tell me your theory
but to say that it does so
this is a description so far we have
nothing you know i need to see your atom
so that i can follow your theory
why it doesn't do that real quick it
does real quick does valence jumping
happen instantaneously without time
yeah uh well valence what do you mean
valence to
conduction band when when the electron
jumps and what about that
instantaneously yeah yeah because that's
that's the other issue the instantaneous
you can explain with a
rope model because you have a balloon
that expands and contracts some
you know so the edge of the balloon
suddenly changes to a smaller
level and then it expands again so now
you can explain this quantum jump
barriers
they ever film the frames between the
jump no no they can't
they can't even see at that level that's
the point we're just talking about
crappy
technology they can't measure it no no
they they determine that
niels bohr determined that in 1911 that
you know
he explained it supposedly you know gave
a really a description he didn't explain
it he just
gave a mathematical description that
there's a different
amount of energy at different levels and
he was able to explain
you know for example the uh spectrum of
hydrogen with that
and that's why he he got us noble and
that's why he was
regarded as a god but the issue is he's
got no explanation to this day we don't
know
what the mechanism is for that what is
you can't use the word energy because
energy is a concept we need a physical
object we need to see
how the atom really works in there i
mean and now we don't have it into this
thing you use the word energy if you
give it shape and contour and tell us
what it looks like and what it's doing i
guess
okay and then uh and then from there we
move on to
what is this to incoherence i call it
it's called the
coherence what is that the loss of
information to the environment
there's interference essentially from
the environment to whatever quantum
phenomena occurs and so they say it's
either entangled
or they're superpositioned or uh or it
could be
decoherence any of those um
oh no there's another one which one did
i miss
the coherence entanglement and
superposition yeah those three can
happen
and they don't know how inhabited they
just said there's interference
especially that last one entanglement
which means there's action at a distance
without any mediator that's that's
called magic
because if you cannot explain that you
don't have a mechanism meaning
you're just putting angels and spirits
in there you know
why does and here you have uh an example
okay
there we go okay here you have uh one
particle on the other side of the
universe this is what they tell you okay
one particle on the other side of the
universe is going counterclockwise this
one's going clockwise
and now when one changes to clockwise
the other one changes to
counterclockwise
instantaneously on the other side of the
universe so if you have one
top here on earth and another one on the
moon
this top a discrete top can affect that
top over there
could we have really good uh phone
signals if we use that technology
well the issue is not instantaneously
yeah yeah the issue is that
we are aware of the technology that you
can use this effect to do
technology what we don't have today what
we don't have is an explanation it's an
explanation
so so the issue is we don't have an
explanation for all that
and and that's what physics is about if
you don't have sure we have explanations
good ones
well yeah i mean irrational ones because
all of them rely on concepts
mathematical concepts meaning all these
mathematicians who took over
so-called physics okay mathematical
physics what they do is they come up
with their equations and they re
they use words which represent equations
force mass energy uh time
all these things that they use to bend
like they bend time they
move the end they transfer energy they
move the mass
there are no such physical objects but
yes it's it comes down to semantics what
they've done is they've turned all these
they
reified all these concepts and they
start moving them around
and you think they're giving you a
physical interpretation when in reality
they haven't done anything all they did
was give you a description
uh which they converted their math into
physics and they
they it's like they go over the x moves
this way
close enough we kick the y over there
and you know what we mean right
if you don't go to school yeah we don't
have a mechanism we don't know how how
the universe works at the micro or macro
level remember macro level we have
bending of time for gravity what the
hell is that what do you mean bending of
time
what do you mean warping of time gravity
warps time a concept warps another
concept
what kind of talk is that that's just
semantics
okay um
i think i had something here on
entanglement
oh yeah these are the questions okay so
let's move on to the questions people
ask
uh from what i saw uh years ago the
entanglement is a mistake
created by how the experiment is set up
and again
uh here uh
[Music]
entanglement itself here you have uh the
the experiment that
um i aspected that i showed the other
day
alan aspect he was a french mathematical
physics
physicist and he did this experiment
where he threw
he had an atom in the center he threw
light in opposite direction from that
same atom
and he was able to do all these fancy
things where he put polarizers there
and he allowed in some cases the light
to go through other times not to go
through
and what he was able to show is that
when the one on the left is clockwise
the one on the right is always
counterclockwise
and so he says yeah entanglement does
indeed happen
okay and i'm not saying it doesn't
happen i'm saying he doesn't have an
explanation of how it happens of
what the mechanism is and so here you
have uh
an experiment i think the experiment is
correct it's not that
the experiment doesn't happen which is
this uh gentleman is questioning
i'm saying it does happen it's just that
uh we have no explanation for it
real quick uh you're saying entanglement
is always that they're opposed one is
clockwise known as counterclockwise it's
never
both clockwise or both counterclockwise
in fact
i think i'm going to show it here
because yeah here it is okay and here
you see
why what the problem is uh one file says
can the spin of fundamental particles be
seen or is an indirect inference of some
behavior
of the particles and so i just give
the example you have two discrete tops
we're assuming that
quantum is mediated by discrete
particles we're just going to call them
tops
and the first problem there is that all
particles of quantum mechanics are point
particles so i don't know how you can
tell that they're spinning and then they
haven't defined the word spin
because spin is not spin but they
insinuate once they tell you we don't
know what spin is but then they go ahead
and use
spin like everybody would use the word
spin so they
they don't define it but they use it and
that's another problem but
here we do it with tops okay so you have
the clockwise and counterclockwise spin
and then when you switch and go from the
clockwise goes to counter clockwise and
then counterclockwise
immediately goes to clockwise well the
question is
how did it happen if there's nothing in
between these two tops okay so this is
the issue
we need to explain the mechanism if you
cannot explain the mechanism i don't
care if you can use it
for technology classical technology
build a computer or whatever
if you don't know what you're doing i
mean you can do the technology yeah but
you still don't have an explanation for
how it's done
you don't still understand how mother
nature does this trick we use magnetism
we don't know what the heck it is yeah
uh you can use magnets yeah i mean you
can get a
one of these pygmies in the jungle and
he can uh pull
with his magnet he can pull um iron
filings
does that mean that he can do technology
because he's able to
use it for some useful purpose does he
know how
and it happens picking up iron files
useful
no no no no no okay i'll i'll put it
better then he's got an arrow and he's
got a
metal point and so he goes going
downwards you know he says
i'll just use the magnet pulls it up you
know so he's got some useful stuff for
you know but he doesn't know how it's
happening
in fact the the uh missionary that went
down there to
christianize him doesn't know how it's
done either he he could pull iron fire
but he doesn't know it's happening so
we're not any better off than the
pygmies in the jungle
okay um so another fellow asks
uh there is once you go ahead and read
it there is
there is be a precise point where one
virtual virtual particle just escapes
the black hole's field and the other
virtual particle is just captured okay
it will not be
at the event horizon right i thought
that's where it was but okay that
is the region where all matter is
captured
the region where particles are radiated
in this way
will necessarily be a lot further out
yeah in other words what he's saying is
the following uh
this is the hawking radiation okay
supposedly
and uh what happens they're saying as
far as i know
it's when a particle of space
remember this is a particle space and
it's uh
made out of positive and negative uh
particle that form the space
particles positive in negative space
yeah that's what it is
they call them positrons and electrons
they combine and supposedly they
annihilate and they turn into empty
space
or a particle of space so anyway you
want to visualize it because
well again we don't have a mechanism for
what's going on they just say it does so
we measured it in the lab here's the
equation and we still don't know the
mechanism please tell me the mechanism
and so what what happens is honking
radiation
is that when the particle approaches
supposedly the event horizon
one of the part when they separate these
space particles
uh the
[Music]
black hole sucks one of them in the
other one is free to go you mean
so a space particle goes towards the
black hole hits the edge
it doesn't go through there it's already
there right at the edge that's what i'm
saying okay it breaks up
so we got a 3d spherical ball in the in
space
yeah whatever in means it's just there
yeah we got a ball in space
and a particle of space whatever that is
hits the edge of this ball
and that particle no no no it doesn't no
no no no hold it
it's the space particle that breaks in
two okay
it breaks into a little bit of
nothingness there you go now we got it
right
we have a zero ball turns into a
positive ball and a negative ball that's
what it is okay when they combine it it
forms a zero ball again the positive one
or the negative one that's it
and what happens in when they separate
momentarily the black hole instantly
sucks one in
all the way to the center of the
singularity the other one is free to go
that's what hawking radiation is they
say that's what he was
saying he's saying we should see light
coming out of a black hole which was
forbidden before that because that's why
it's black
but he says yeah we should see radiation
coming out of a black hole that we can
measure down here why because
the just to say just to use one other
part let's say all the negative
particles
uh are the ones that are free to go just
arbitrarily okay so all the negative
particles are able to go
to leave and that's the light we should
receive it's called
hawking radiation from a black hole now
that supposedly takes place at the event
horizon
and this guy is saying no no it doesn't
occur at the event horizon look
it's much farther it's the field that's
affected or the region known as field
again
that's affected by the black hole which
is beyond the event horizon it happens
where
you see there on the farthest right
that's where it happens it doesn't
happen close to the event horizon
and the issue is first he's wrong okay
no it happens right at the event horizon
because that's where you have the
velocity of light supposedly
that's where you have the escape
velocity okay and uh
equal to light that's what event horizon
is right farther out well you know
that's just the same as a sun
a star in other words a star also has a
field
so it doesn't happen at a around a star
as well
and the answer is no they only talk
about hawking radiation being
close to the end to the event horizon so
he
he's uh mistaken on that issue okay
this fellow is wrong he's gotta
do a little research on this and he'll
find out that he is not
quite right okay uh a couple more
questions then we'll move on to today's
questions we got a few of them there
okay uh time flies when you're having
fun
okay uh go ahead read it we always
illustrate the rope between two atoms
atoms a and b
as having the same frequency link length
yeah
what would it look like if you
illustrated the rope having different
frequency link lengths between a and b
which i guess is how it is
well the issue yeah the issue is the
following i just try to
make a little picture of it so that we
can follow along
first of all you have gazillions of
ropes i didn't draw the gazillion ones
okay
converging on an atom the atom is
expanding and contracting it's vibrating
it's doing all this
motion but we're just going to
concentrate on the expansion and
contraction
but it's receiving atoms it's re it's um
it's ropes are converging upon that atom
from every atom in the universe
some are very far away okay so the
signal you can imagine it
comes uh relatively slowly could be high
frequency you know
you got all kinds of uh well some are
some
you got all kinds of stuff there now
imagine you have a little uh
laser and you're very close to that atom
you know maybe it's the wall
adam on the wall and now you stimulate
it with your laser
okay well the stimulus from that laser
has to be a lot stronger than
other influences from atoms that are on
the other side of the universe
okay so if you stimulate it with your
laser it's going to shine
and not because there's an influence
from outside the universe
okay uh or not outside of you but very
far from there keep it there i want to
ask questions oh okay
let's put it there uh not because of
that are you gonna
say that the influence from that it's
going to overrule the local
influence that's my point so you have
all these
influences upon an atom and remember you
have
lots of atoms in the vicinity gazillions
of them that have much more
influence over your atom than atoms that
are very very far away even
as far away as the sun for example not
to mention even further
so you got to look at this you got to
look at all the frequencies all the
wavelengths that are coming approaching
an atom from every angle okay and i was
just thinking this is interesting
because i never really
considered so much the fact that it's
true every rope that goes into an atom
does have a different frequency doesn't
it yes which is weird
it's weird but remember um because you
have
i'm all i'm saying is that logo has to
be separated from the far away the
farther
you are there's going to be a difference
of influence over that atom that's my
point okay but i just got a quick
question on this i don't want to go so
into it but yeah
if assuming i'm gonna make you sweat
if we if let's say that the shell of the
atom which is what's pumping
yeah goes out i mean i don't want to
i don't know what let's say a nanometer
i don't know what the right uh amount
would be
okay yeah a unit yeah that unit
in every rope would be a different
amount of
links that it eats yeah isn't that weird
uh yeah not not completely
uh depends again what the st where the
greatest stimulus is
if again if if i point a laser for
example when we do the slit experiment
or i i deal with a needle experiment if
i point a laser to it
that laser has a lot more influence than
the
non-uh that means you know my reflection
from the sun
or the lamp hits me then goes to the
needle yeah it's going to receive a
stimulus from that atom right here you
know that's
connected to that specific atom right
but the laser is going to influence that
a lot more than
you know a a dull reflection for example
and so the stimulus is going to depend
primarily on the
on the one that's the strongest just to
say
in those terms we'll talk about
directions and and we're only talking
about one atom with another atom
let alone the gazillions of because
remember when you have a laser pointer
you gotta get zillions of atoms there uh
that are being stimulated right there
all in one direction all on that atom
and on a group of atoms and they're
going to stimulate those atoms
much more than the sun through the walls
right inside your room and so we got to
look at
all this stuff because it all has a
bearing on it
and yeah the atom is pumping and it's uh
essentially
a uh an aggregate
don't erase us it's an aggregate
uh of all the stimulus that's how much
the that atom is to pump
uh outwards because it's receiving
stimulus from all of them and at
different points in time
but some are going to overrule the
others and that's the one that's going
to trigger the atom to pump
at a given rate and that changes from
second to second because suddenly it
receives another stimulus from somewhere
else
and you know it's it becomes a monster
after a while and that's why quantum
mechanics
cannot figure a lot of these um
phenomena
because you get all these influences
that they can't measure they
that they don't know how they're where
they're coming from
and so they say well let's do it
mathematically let's just describe
what's happening
because they cannot explain it i love
the rope model because it gives you
something to work with at least
to imagine to visualize you something
visually you go well
okay assuming this assuming this
phenomenon were true how could we
explain it
yeah at least it gives you something to
have in your head instead of just a
bunch of
and here's along the same line the same
fellow says same for amplitude
if a's amplitude is say twice of b's
but the same frequency link length then
does that mean
b is receiving twice the rope slash
thread
is this how we perceive receiving energy
from the sun
the extra incoming thread causes the
atoms to vibrate
more and we feel heat and then another
fellow responds to him
along the same line i can't quite
imagine how you can have
amplitude in this rope model i've heard
of it having wavelength and frequency
but i don't see the ropes expanding to
create amplitude i don't understand it
to be that way
and so here's a little picture okay
let's go one at a time here's the first
one
and this is the way quantum explains it
they have this um
standing wave usually they don't put it
they don't illustrate amplitude with uh
transverse waves in other words the the
typical transverse waves that's made of
all these vectors right
what they do is they put a standing wave
a little single line it goes up and down
because that's what we see on the
oscilloscope for example
and then if the wave is uh taller
then we say it's a high amplitude it's
shorter we say it's low amplitude
and what what essentially we haven't
changed any of this
and all we did is we replaced that which
you're seeing there with a rope model
okay and so all i can tell you is uh
here's the rope model
okay i like the gift this gift on the
bottom really
it shows it well and and then here you
see the rope amplitude okay
this is what we're saying is happening
and again all we're doing is
mimicking imitating what they've done
with a wave all we're saying is that the
same thing is being done with a rope
and remember that during
magnetism it's the threads that separate
and they swing around so the threads do
separate
and i think that's what amplitude is
that's the way i visualize that i'm just
saying that the links
are taller if we're just going to talk
about tall and short
uh in the up and down direction we're
just going to say that
the threads are separated a little more
than they were before
is actually to say that magnetism is the
highest form of amplitude then
you could say that yeah but remember
they also swing around well yeah
in fact on the rope and it's still
torquing while well it's
you know what it's separated by stream
amplitude yeah yeah
i think this is all it is that's all
we're seeing there
we're just seeing the thread is more
separated from its uh neighbor
that's all we we think it is okay
and okay i think we can open up the
uh floor for uh questions
live questions go ahead we don't have
that many okay
now start at the top there let me get
let me do that
you're slow oh i'm too slow
i'm old uh i'm going around 70. okay go
ahead get a lot of questions
uh oh we talked about urban environment
uh is there i mean i guess i'll
translate the
question oh where did i click no um get
rid of that
is there any difference between animals
and us regarding
uh extinction due to our
capacity to use technology just can't
technology no because i'd say that
technology has nothing to do with the
extinction
that's just our particular um way of
operating that we
have all this comfort because we created
all this technology
but the real issue is economic collapse
it has to do with the plants
ultimately remember we're specifically
growing plants that we've that we eat
and that we've eaten for a long time
a lot of those plants are losing their
genetic diversity because
we are cloning them you know a lot of
those plants are being cloned
others just lose their genetic diversity
simply because of
mother nature's job you know they they
inbreed for so many
centuries and then at some point what
happens is
that uh ecology collapses
it collapses because we don't produce in
in our case we don't produce
the um the food that we eat
and so it's it's eventually it has to do
with the plants but it doesn't have to
do with the technology it has to do with
money
money is what disappears our system
collapses and we don't produce
the food that we did in the past even
though we have the technology to do so
we have no monetary incentive to do so
i guess it's going to be the same thing
just with extra steps
the same extinction event as as
with dinosaurs yeah i'm saying i'm
saying
what kills us is uh what i call the
vitals
you can't breathe you can't eat you
can't drink you can't sleep
those are the vitals mother nature
attacks the vitals that's how she does
extinction
uh mass extinction and and so the issue
is if we have nothing to eat if we have
nothing to drink
for sure we're going to die i think
that's guaranteed i don't i don't think
too many people have challenged that
and i'm saying that the reason we eat
today the reason we
eat today is that we produce our food
ourselves and we do it only because of
money
if money happens to collapse because we
have a uh
an economic collapse no one produces the
food which is what keeps us alive which
attacks one of the vitals
especially food but drinks as well i
don't understand this question i don't
know if you do
why don't we see ropes with amf or ato
second
laser pulses omega seeing ropes
seeing ropes that's where you fail
already why can't we see ropes
yeah we can't see ropes i showed that
the other day when uh when you have uh
i'd have to show the uh gif again but
what it is
is remember the rope come directly to
your finger this one one scenario there
are several scenarios but one is that
the ropes come into your hand as you
move it forward right
and so it's like sliding a beat on the
abacus
what you have is the atom is eating on
the rope itself because the rope
comprises
the atom that's sliding through it so
you you can never see the rope in front
of you because the rope makes
up the atom that's sliding through it
and so
you know you can't touch a rope and so
that's where you
you don't have to put any thing be
beyond that all you got is
that you can't see a rope you got to
forget about the intouch anyone who
talks about c
and touch is focusing on the wrong
definition of the word object an object
is not that which you can see and touch
an object is that which has shape
and it doesn't mean you can see your
touch again you can't touch
an object on the other side of the
universe does that mean it's not an
object
you can't see that object is that why
it's not an object i can't see an object
that's in china right now does that mean
it's not an object
so c touch is the wrong criteria it's
for people who
think that they go into the lab and
they're going to be able to see and
touch the mediator of light
have we ever seen particles uh photons
no we have never seen a photon it's an
assumption
that there are all these discrete
particles that form a beam of light
well talking about an object on the
other side of the universe
i his last question it goes to
entanglement
um under the rope model we
are assuming the
entanglement experiments
are where what accepting the assumptions
of the entanglement
uh experiments and we're and we're
trying to explain entanglement
with the ropes so we have entanglement
under the rope model
yeah can we do
well what you have is you do have a
connection through a physical connection
through the rope
okay yeah my two fists again maybe
that's the way to do it
my two fifths are the atom and there you
have the rope so if this one's
torquing in a given direction right and
the atom is pumping
back and forth remember the atom expands
and contracts
yeah huh camera got a bit blurry but i
guess right now oh okay
and uh so so what you have is two atoms
tied by a rope
and so when this atom expands and
contracts and torques the rope
it influences this atom okay the other
issue is that you know
when this yeah entanglement uh for light
at least okay when this
uh rope this end of the rope i measure
it going clockwise
yours had better be going
counterclockwise and when i turn mine
clockwise you should go counterclockwise
but that
there's a problem there because there is
the instantaneous
instantaneousness i guess of
yeah it doesn't unroll and roll in time
it either goes one direction or the
other yeah
the other issue there is that you get
that part yeah but the problem there is
see we got to do these experiments under
the rope model under the interpretation
of the rope model
are we measuring the same photon
so-called photon
i mean what you have is gazillions of
ropes there and the question is which
rope did you
select when they say oh we we were able
to measure
uh polarization now we have to go into
detail but see i use a polarizer you
know
it's called an ellipsometer and it's got
an analyzer and a polarizer
and it turns out you get a bunch of
light and and it just measures
or or at that point what it does is uh
you know it accepts the beam of light
and it says it's polarized
north south or east west that's
essentially what it does okay it gives
you a number for that
because it's to determine the thickness
of a layer
of film such as silicon dioxide but
here's the point the point is
it's like they cut across a whole bunch
of ropes
okay and so these people are saying oh
we measured
one photon did you or did you measure
gazillions of photons
and think that you're measuring one
photon prove to me
i mean if they like proof prove to me
that you measured one photon
okay that you handled one photon at a
time that's the issue
and so these people are getting away
with murder when they say that
um that they measure one photon so they
handle one electron at a time
the devil's in the details yeah because
uh they didn't
you know and so the question is did they
measure that same
um rope
and if you measure the one next to it
that one's going in the opposite
direction well this one's going
counterclockwise over there it's
clockwise fine how about this one over
here well this is clockwise and the
other one's going counterclockwise how
do you know which one you're measuring
how do you know if you measured a bundle
of them
i mean that's why this has to be revised
under the rope model
okay that's it
uh okay no more questions
i mean there's there's a few but you can
go through those in your time
okay
[Laughter]
okay any rational questions those
valence and the jumping happen
instantaneously
yeah yeah okay that's i guess yeah it
does
there are questions
it only looks like magic until we
understand it yeah but the problem is we
don't have any explanation from quantum
mechanics
so if you don't have an explanation then
you don't understand it it is magic
it's like um this fellow um uh nick
lucid
he's got a video probably gonna analyze
it in the future
saying that quantum is not magic and
then he goes out there and he tries to
explain certain things like entanglement
and
of course he does a lousy job because he
uses the word wave
there is no physical object called wave
and so he starts out on the wrong
foot he's saying that he goes with a
wave and then he tries to explain it
with a wave
if there is no physical object called
wave he cannot use the word wave
therefore he doesn't have an explanation
and if he doesn't have an explanation
it is quantum magic because he's putting
spirits in there that he calls
objects that's the problem an object is
that which has shape
not that which you can see or touch
okay with that we'll see you what uh on
sunday
we'll see you then bye-bye